يا مرحبا حياكم الله
نورتوا المكان
اتفضلوا ونورتو قريه
زمانه الماضي وعاداته وتقاليده في قريه
زمان التي تعكس الثقافه السعوديه باكلاتها
الشعبيه وعروض الزفاف ذات البهجه والالوان
السعيده
قريه زمان تاخذنا لام مزنه التي تنتظر
زوارها بصالتها المملوئه بادوات ما عادت
مالوفه عند جيل اليوم ومعلوم الرجال فهو
مكان الاختبار الحقيقي لعادات وتقاليد
الشعب السعودي مثل صب القهوه
[موسيقى]
الحفلات الغنائيه ارتدت الطابعه القديم
بصوت الفنان عمر سليمان الذي اطرب حضور
قريه زمان بصوته الشعبي ضمن الفعاليات
موسم الرياضه
بدول الغربيه بس المهرجان هذا مميز لانه
اول شيء دوله عربيه
واتكلم مع كل الناس
مع كل الجمهور باللغه العربيه
لذلك انا مرتاح جدا
وقدم تحياتي الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
على هذا المهرجان موسم الرياض
احبك احبك العربيه